カルナの場合は これは簡単に助けたいという行持なんですね
なんとかしてあげたいと
なんとか助けたいと ですから
慈悲よりは慈しむよりは本当は難しいんですけどね
でもなんか世の中を見ると
みんなそこら辺だけかっこいいと思ってるんですね
なんかいいことをしましたから
人を助けたんだと だからそこら辺は理解しやすいんですね
すごく誰か苦しんでる
悩んでる誰かをね ちょっとなんとかしてあげただけで大変喜びを感じるという気持ちなんですけど
でももっと性格ができないってない人にはそんなにできるわけじゃないんですね
だから自分が大丈夫だと
やっぱり人々は悩んではいけませんと
人々は苦しんではいけませんと
ということで この人々の苦しみを対象にして瞑想させるんですね
例えば今頃聞こえるかもしれませんだけど
まあ野良猫たちの まあ何て言いますか
恋の歌聞こえますからね
そこで あの 猫ちゃんだとまあ頑張ってくださいと思うのは慈しみの気持ちで
やっぱり苦しんでるなとね
雨が降っても寒くても
その時はもう外に出ないです
ご飯も食べない まあ夜は夜行性だからね
大体寝ませんだけどね
そこで苦しみを見えてしまう
その猫の そうやって生命の苦しんでるところ見えてくる
この人も大変だと この人はもう考え方で見れば大変だと
そうやって見る見方がカルナの瞑想ですね
それで全ての生命が本当は大変なんです
たとえ神々であろうと梵天であろうが関係なく
みんな大変なんです 輪廻だから
こんな人生に楽っていうものは解脱以外はないんです
そのその世界にはそれぞれ厳しさがあるんです
犬の世界には犬の厳しさがありまして
チンパンジーの世界にはそちらにいろいろ厳しさがありまして
人間の世界にはそれで厳しさがありまして
我々は猫を見て猫は楽ですよと
それはもう もう大違いであって
で 猫たちの世界ではちゃんとそれなりの厳しさがあるんです
猫も大変なんです 犬も
まあ犬のことを人間にはよくわかるでしょうね
はっきり言って犬っていうのはいかに苦労しているかというと
人間に飼われて だから人間に飼われて苦労しているというよりは
まあ犬もやっぱり飼われてほしいという気持ちはありますけど
でもちゃんと自分を飼ってるんだから
この飼い主のために飼い主の機嫌をちゃんと取って
気持ちをね 穏やかな気持ちにしてあげて
なんとかしようとね もう人間みたいに考える脳細胞もないのに
すっごい苦労しているんです
そこで一日中縛っているとかね
それでもストレス溜まって吠えちゃったらもう怒られるでしょ
これは良くないと我慢して吠えないでいるでしょ
ちゃんと躾しているんだとか
偉そうにみんな威張ったりするんだけどね
いくら躾したって犬が吠えたければ吠えるんだからね
でもこれは嫌なことだと
人間にとってはとわかったらもう吠えませんし
ですから そのその生命っていうのは自分の世界ですごく苦しんで大変なんですね
生きているということは
生き続くということか
そうやってすごく苦労して生きてる
その側面を見る瞑想がカルナ瞑想なんですね
ムディター瞑想っていうのはこの機能瞑想だから
それだけやる場合はまた逆の立場で見ているんですね
まあそれなりに頑張ってるんじゃないかと
それなりに大変ということではなくて
まあそのその世界で みんなまあ頑張ってるんだと
応援しましょうと 両方一応持ってますよ
猫も飼われたならば 犬も飼われたならば
もうそれそれで幸せでしょうに
ちゃんと餌をもらっちゃうし
よく遊んでくれるし もう可愛がってもらうし
お手って言ったら手を出したりとか何とかして
まあ犬はあれで結構楽しいでしょう
ですから まあとにかくその生命が生きてるということは
その次元でそれなりに元気で頑張ってるということなんです
元気で頑張らないと その生命が死んじゃうでしょ
人間の場合ははっきりわかりますからね
もうダメだと この生命は
生き方は この人生は もう何の楽しみも何もないんだと思ったら
すぐ自殺する 自分に合う問題
自分にある問題はもう解決できないんだとわかったら
もう自殺 動物でも同じなんですね
もうダメやと思ったら
その場で生きることを諦めるんです
誰かに狙われてると逃げようとします
もうダメやとわかったら
何のことなく捕らわれてもらう
食べられても諦める そういう意味
子供はね 動物でもものすごい真剣に自分の子供を守ってるでしょ
それでも子供 他の動物に狙われてると
とにかく頑張るんですけどね
守ろうと でもやっぱりダメやとわかったら諦めるんですね
ですから とにかく生命が生きているということは
これ死ぬということは意味がないんですから
とにかく生命は生きているんだからね
その点ではね 生きてるということは
それなりにうまくいってるということなんです
それなりにうまくいっている
ですから その その側面で生命を見ることはムディターの瞑想なんですね
例えばホームレスの人がもう十年目になりましたと
ホームレス生活は 十年間も頑張ったんでしょうに
まあそれなりにうまくいったっていうことなんです
もし食べるものも何もなかったのならば死んじゃうでしょ
冬は体を温める方法何もなかったならば
もうそれで冬死ぬでしょうに
ということは 例えば年間ホームレスやっていた人のことを観察すると
それなりにその人もまあ
自分の人生をね なんとか頑張ってるんじゃないかと
いろいろ工夫したりとかね
ある場所から追い出しちゃうと
また他のどこかへ行って
そこでテントを張っているとかね
そこから追い出しちゃったら
また他のところに行って
そこでまたテント張ってとか
そうやってどんどんこの
それも自分の人生から瞑想始まるんですね
自分が自分の人生いろいろ観察してみると
いろんないいとこあったんだから今まで生きてきたんだと
悪いことだけだったら今まで生きてるわけじゃないんですね
だからいっぱい良いことあったんだから
死なないで今まで生きてきてる
生きてきたんだからね
だから生きてるということ自体が良いことあったという証拠なんですね
環境はよくまあうまく自分に適したということなんですね
ですから 物は見方次第で変わりますからね
みんな大変だと見るとみんな大変なんです
でも条件はまあそれももう結構揃ってるんだから
みんな生きてるでしょうね
ですから それだったらまあなかなか頑張ってるんじゃないかと
なかなか恵まれてるんではないかというふうに言えるんですね
そういうことで 一日生きていられるということは
一日自分に対してはいい条件
いいコンディションが揃っているということなんです
その点でまた生命を見る
自分を見る 他人を見る
すべての生命を見て 瞑想するとムディター瞑想が成長する
ウペッカー瞑想はあのやっぱり
あの仲間という特別な手段もなく
あれはちょっとした手段なんですね
生命は平等ですよと理解するために
みんな大変だと思うことも感情的な手段なんです
みんななかなか頑張ってるんじゃないかと
頑張れるという条件が揃ってるんじゃないかと
みんな恵まれてるんじゃないかと
恵まれてなかったら死んじゃいますよと
その点で見ることも 生命は平等であるということを理解するための手段なんです
その感情 ですから 慈悲喜
三つも感情なんですね
そんな感情なくても平等は平等だからね
感情置いといて平等だけ見ることはウペッカー瞑想なんですね
わざわざと色眼鏡なくても見えると
慈しみという色眼鏡で見たら
みんな同じ色やと思うか
あのカルナという色眼鏡でやっぱりみんな同じ色やつ見るか
あるいはムディターという色眼鏡で見て
やっぱりみんな同じ色やつ見るか
眼鏡置いといてみんな同じやつ見るか
どっちかな そういう風にこの慈悲喜捨の瞑想ですね
で 慈悲喜捨の瞑想はとことん仏教で勧めている瞑想なんですね
ヴィパッサナー瞑想と慈悲喜捨の瞑想はちゃんと両立してやってほしいと
なぜかというと 解脱するまですべての生命と一緒に生きていなくちゃいけない
心っていうのは全部つなげているんだから
空気と同じなんです 空気の分子は一つだったら一つですけどね
他のものと関係ないんだけど
でもやっぱり空気全部つなげてるんですね
つなげてるんだけど 別に空気一部取ろうと思ったら取れる
[笑い]空気の一つのモレキュールと英語で言うんです
分子かな？どっちかな
わかりませんだけど 一個だけ取りたければ
それも取れる 我々の心はまあ同じもんなんですね
水と同じ 水も同じでしょうね
水の一つだけ分子取りたければそれもできるし
ほんのちょっと取りたければそれもできるし
全部まとめて見たらそれもできる
ですから 人間っていうのは自分というものは解脱するまでみんなと一緒に生きていなくちゃいけないでしょ
ですから 慈悲の瞑想するのは当たり前のことで
それで解脱体験しても
死ぬまでまたちょっと残ってるんですね
何年か ですから まあその分でも慈悲の瞑想ということをまあ実行してみるということで
仏教では大変ありがたい瞑想になっています
このテキストでのあの高井さんのチャートで
このウペッカーはなんで番目の禅定だけ書いてますかね
これ一 二 三 四 四も生まれるんじゃないんですか
どっから引っ張って来たんだかわかってないです
ん？ どっかに説明があって
そこから勝手に書いたわけじゃなくて
どっかに説明が  とにかくこの第五禅定に丸入れてますけど
一から全部に丸入れてください
初禅 第二禅 三禅 四禅 五禅
全部生まれるんです このチャートのその二と書いてるところで九番目なんですね
そちらでこの  ジャーカパッカ・ヴィバーガっていうところがあって
多分そこから取った そこを読んでこれ丸つけたんだと思います
まあ知ってます なぜそうなったかっていうこと
そういうところで違うことを言いたかった
いわゆるこの慈悲喜で第四禅定までですよと
第五番目は生まれませんと
第五番目は捨ですよということを言いたがってるんですね
そこでちょっと捨の瞑想で第五だと思っちゃいましたかもしれません
じゃなくて 第五生まれるということは
一から全部生まれるということなんです
ここ説明するしているところはそういうふうにちょっとあのなんかちょっと説明ちょっと何か曲がってるというかね
だから皆様には覚えやすいでしょうね
例えば慈悲喜までは第四禅定までできる
ということは 一 二 三 四
四もできる でも第五番目の禅定も作りたいなと思って
いくらメッターバーヴァーナしても第五番目の禅定は生まれません
論理的でしょうね メッターっていうのは感情だからね
感情なしに作ることだから
第五番目 あるいは一般的な経典だったら第四禅定ですね
そこで第五番目の禅定も作りたければ
慈悲喜捨の場合は捨のウペッカー瞑想だけなんです
ウペッカーバーヴァーナだけです
ウペッカーバーヴァーナ最初からやる人が第一禅定も二も三も四も五も作られます
飛ぶことはできません
それは不可能です もしメッターバーヴァーナした人が第四禅定まで行ったならば
まあ次のステップに行きますと思ったら
彼がウペッカーバーヴァーナにスイッチ入れ替える
入れ替えてまた一 二 三
四 四 五でやらなくちゃいけないんです
でもその人にはもう経験がありますから
一 二 三 四 四はもうすぐすぐ早く行きますけど
やっぱりウペッカーで五まで行くんです
メッターカルナームヴィターは四で止まる
あの経典の禅定の場合は三で終わる
まあとにかくアビダンマでは第一禅定を二つに分離しているんです
それだけの差 経典で第一禅定というものはアビダンマの世界で一
二にしているんです 第二の禅定
三禅定 四禅定 全部同じ
経典でもアビダンマでも
第一禅定は二つに分けてます
それで第五禅になってるんです
では 次の二つの瞑想を説明します
サンニャーという瞑想
これサンニャーと言わない
大体アーハーリパティクルサンニャーと全部いっぺんに言うんです
サンニャー瞑想って言っちゃったら
なんかちょっとわからないでしょうね
思うことなんですね それはどういうものかというと
この食べ物に対して いかなる生命であろうか
欲があるんですね すごい執着があるんです
決まってるんです 食べ物によって喜び
快感感じなきゃ食べないんです
食べなきゃ死ぬんです
だから死なないために食べ物から快感感じるんです
何を食べても ですから
人間食べないものは他の生命は食べてるし
その人々はまあそれで生命はそれで快感は感じている
まああのハイエナとかね
まあ腐ってる もうものすごいひどい臭いする
この動物のね まあ死んだもの食べてるでしょうね
そのハイエナもすごい快感感じてるんです
だからまあ食っていうのは何でもいいんです
もう食べ物っていうのは地水火風だからね
チースイカーフだからもうみんなチースイカーフ取ってるだけなんですけどね
でも快感感じなきゃもうこの感も空き缶になっちゃったんだけどね
それもチースイカーフなんです
これ食べてもいいんですけど
快感は感じないんですね
だから食べないんです
そこで人間にしたっても
みんな同じもの食べてるんだけど
それぞれまた違うでしょうね
食べ物は 食べ物か料理方法で見たまま違うでしょ
それまあどんな方法で快感感じるかっていうことで
ですから 食べ物の基本的な心の感情は欲なんですね
人殺しまでするんですよ
食べ物なくなっちゃうと
欲がなくなると怒りが生まれるんです
欲と怒りっていうのは表と裏だから
だから食べ物に対して戦争までも起こります
この感情 仏教ではこれ心清らかにするために
心の煩悩をなくすためには
これすごいいいものやと
全く違う角度で見るんです
一番自分に対して一番汚い醜いものは食べ物です
だから食べ物を食べたらどうなるんですかね
口に入った途端 もう口の中ではもうものすごい汚いものになっている
別に論科学的に同じものだと
それだったら科学的に全部選んで食べたことは食べないでしょうね
ですから 口に入った瞬間でもう嫌なものになっちゃう
お腹に入ったらもっとひどくなる
腸で流れるともっとひどい
大腸の方に行ったらものすごく嫌なものなんですね
ですから それが不思議なことは自分に対してなんです
で 日本では経験ないかもしれませんだけど
この私たちはこの牛の糞ありますね
また山羊の糞とかね あれいろんなこの肥料に使う
決して捨てません 牛の糞
牛の糞は牛糞は決して捨てません
あれはもう大変価値あるものなんですね
だから拾ったりもする
拾って集めて まあ他の葉っぱとかいろんなものを入れたりして
いくらかあの肥料として整えたところ
ところでまあ肥料に使う
あるいはこの昔の壁なんか作る場合は
この骨組みをまず竹なんかで作って
それからこの牛の糞と土ですね
土を大体このシロアリの土が一番いいんですね
で そちらも粘りがありますからね
土自体に 自体に それとあれ混ぜてある
まあ割り当てありますけどね
まあ大体わかりませんけども
昔はもう遠い昔の時はいたんだけど
1対1ではないんです
まあ1対8ぐらいかな
土は多めに入れて あれで混ぜて壁なんかに塗ったりすると
あの割れ目も入りませんし
乾かしちゃうと それであの植物ものだから結構この殺菌作用やらありまして
カビとかも出てこないし
かなりいいもんなんです
インドではあの燃料としても使ってますね
干して燃料に インドはものすごい牛がいっぱいいるんだから
そこでなぜ そうで 私たちの国々の人間にとっては
牛の糞というのは汚いものでも何でもないんです
そこでまあ子供にとっては嫌だと思うから怒るんだよね
嫌じゃなくて自分の手で取ってこちらに入れなさいと
でも一回二回入れちゃったら全然何のことなくもう触ったりすることもできます
そこで私たちはまあちょっと手を洗ったら
手がものすごく綺麗になるんです
あちらかなりなんかいい成分いろいろあるみたいですね
まあ葉っぱいくらかね
もう消化したものだから
それでこの我々の あの何て言いますか
バナナとか ココナッツ木の若い時とか
牛が必ず狙うんですね
これを で引っ張ったりする
引っ張ったら木が折れちゃう
この 2つもココナッツのバナナもちょっと倒れちゃったら
頭の方がちょっと折れたらそれで死んじゃうんですからね
枝はないんだから これ大変な損なんですね
で 我々どうしますかっていうと
牛の糞を水で溶かして拭いておくんです
葉っぱに 牛は食べない
いくら美味しいバナナ
バナナの葉っぱであろうとも食べない
そこら辺の芝いろいろ食べるんだけど
あれは食べません だから牛にとってはすっごい嫌なものでしょ
すごい簡単な方法なんです
で 人間にとっても同じことなんです
人間の便は 一番嫌なものなんです
だから人間 だから論理的に考えたら
人間がご飯やら野菜やらこれまで一番いいもの
牛は一番いいものを食べてるわけじゃないんです
我々野菜とって全然役に立たない食べられないものだけ牛に食べさせてますから
だから一番美味しいもの
一番いいところ 例えばマンゴーにしたっても
我々はマンゴーの中身食べて
マンゴーの葉っぱは葉っぱ
皮が牛にあげるんです
皮はほんのちょっと苦くて
人間には食べられませんから
それだったら牛の糞よりは人間の便が一番綺麗でしょうに
自分の触ったり 手で触ったりとかね
例えば壁を塗ったりしたければ
それといろいろ土やら色
それで混ぜて塗ったりすれば一番いいでしょうに
材料はいいんだから でも違うでしょ
だから肉の場合もすごい汚いものばっかり食べてる
鶏やら豚やら それで魚とかね
何食べてるかっていうと
とんでもないものを食べてるんだけど
それはおいしく食べるんだけど
一番世の中で高級なものを食べているのは人間ですから
一番おいしいのは人間の肉じゃないかなと思いますけど
でも人間にとってはものすごいそれ嫌なものでしょう
まあライオンや虎とかね
動物は食べてますけど
間違ってでも自分の種類の肉は食べませんでしょ
あれは食べません 他の群れのある虎の群れ群れがいて
他の虎の子が見たら あいつを取って食べようかと
それはしません そんな下品なことするのは魚だけ
それは人間にとって一番美味しいものになっているんですね
そこでこの食べ物っていうのは
本当は食べる瞬間だけ
食べる前の瞬間だけ欲がいっぱいあって
なんかバカげた演技やってるんです
そんなバカげた演技やらなくたって
もう瞬時にそれもう汚いものになっちゃうんです
例えばいくら美味しく食べたって
食べ残しに対してどんな気持ち見ると楽しいんですか？食べて終わってから半分食べて半分残したところ
気持ち悪いでしょうに
まあ嫌でしょうに さっさと早く早く洗わな洗ってもしなくちゃ
ですから 食べる場合は
これは瞬時に一番汚いものになるんだと
口に入った瞬間に汚いものになるんだと
と観察すると あの瞬間で生まれてくるあの欲
ああ 美味しいんだ 脂がのって今は旬ですよとかね
よく言うでしょうに 私の食欲をなくしたければ
その一言葉で十分です
今は旬ですから これすごく脂がのって美味しいです
って聞いた瞬間でもう触りたくも見たくもなくなっちゃうんです
僕らの見方が違いますからね
だからそう時々言われますけど
その時もどうしようもなく食べますけど
なんかすごいもう 大変苦しむんです
精神的に そういうことで
この すごい欲が生まれるので
その瞬間に欲をなくしちゃえば
これはもうものすごい便利なものなんです
すごい便利なものなんです
だからお釈迦様はそういう人間の心を育てるポイントを見つけたら
これはもうとことん使うんだからね
他の宗教ではそういうふうなところはおそらくないだろうと思います
ですから 瞑想一時間  怒りとパティクーラと違いというのはどういう違いなんでしょうか
嫌だっていうか 嫌だっていう
これは汚い 嫌だっていう怒りとパティクーラ
だからパティクーラっていうのはあの普段
いいものだと思うものに対して生まれるんです
例えば食べ物の場合は怒り生まれませんでしょ
それは本当は不浄なものやと観察すると生まれる感覚はパティッククーラであって
嫌なものだと思っちゃったらもうどうせ食べないんです
例えばこの食べようと思ったお好み焼き持ってきて食べようと思ったら
そこに虫が歩いてるんだと
見たらもう食べないんでしょ
その時はもしかすると怒りが生まれてくるんですね
それですごくいい香りが出てきて
まあ食欲が湧いてきて
そこでこんなことがあっても
これは一秒足らず汚いものになるんだと
あの出てきた欲をなくしてもらう
消してもらう そこはパティッククーラ・サンニャーなんです
このパティッククーラっていうのはパーリ典出てこないんだけど
このパーリ語でこの食べ物にだけ使ってますけど
この三十二のあの不浄観の場合も
私たちはパティッククーラという言葉を使ってるんですね
それは我々の国の言葉で
で そこでもやっぱりなぜかというと
体 自分の体は自分にとっては一番可愛いものなんですね
あるのは欲のみ 体に対して
その体を 三十二に分析してみると
あ なんだこれはっていう感じになっちゃうんですね
そんな可愛いものでも何でもないんだと
そこで生まれるのはまたパティッククーラなんですね
もう一つ差があります
怒りは自動的に生まれる
何をしなくていつでもありますね
日常 23  24時間も パティッククーラっていうのは智慧をもって観察する時だけ生まれると
もう一つ瞑想がありますね
ワワッターナ これ差別と書いてますけどね
おそらく区別でしょうね
区別という意味もないんですけどね
まあ分類するとかね 分別するとかね
まあ差別もこの文字通りで見ると別に大したことはないんだからね
まあ一応分別する 分類するという
あのちゃんと知識に基づいて分類することはワワッターナなんですね
いい加減な分類ではなくて
ちゃんとカテゴリーに入れて
いる瞑想で 瞑想としてはもう何のこともないんです
自分の体をあの地水火風に分けてみる
体の硬い働きは地です
パタウィで流れている働きは水で
体の熱は火で 体の空間やら体の中で空気自体もいっぱい動いてるでしょうにね
それは風だと それでそれは四つでできてるんだと
だから私がいるんじゃなくて地水火風があるんだと瞑想すること
その二つからもやっぱりこの欲がなくなる
あのアーハル・パティック・サンニャーからは当然欲がなくなっちゃうんですね
無執着なところが生まれてくる
チャルダヌ・ワスタラナからはこの自我意識というかね
高慢とかね そういうものは消えてしまうんですね
自分がいるという感覚
ですから 禅定なんかは生まれてきません
その代わりにすごい智慧が生まれてくる
あの 最後の四つの瞑想
で そこは今日は説明はしませんだけど
アビダンマのところで心のところで私は明確にこの禅定のことを説明しましたから
まだ繰り返しはしたって意味がないんです
今はこのサマーディ瞑想の中で今まで説明したのは
いくらか色界の禅定の瞑想と仏教的な瞑想と仏教の純粋な仏教だけ発見した瞑想の場合はこの第一禅定が生まれてこないんです